bonsoir à toutes et à tous alors je me
suis ni météorologues
ni mathématicien ce soir je vais vous
proposer de l'émotion du coeur je
m'appelle mirin sous rageur essonne je
suis artiste chanteur musicien et avant
de commencer je voudrais d'abord vous
dire pourquoi j'aime tant ce que je fais
donc la musique c'est avant tout une
histoire de famille chez moi tout le
monde chante et pluvieux jusqu'au plus
petit est d'ailleurs ce soir je ne suis
pas venu tout seul
j'aimerais vous présenter ma grande
soeur aînée dessous ayé c'est ma façon
de dire bonjour en dessous qui a
beaucoup contribué à mon amour pour la
scène
étant très jeune et au ciné lings ma
petite nièce
bonsoir qui fait aujourd'hui partie de
l'aventuré alors nous sommes originaires
de madagascar et en plus de ça nous
sommes loir et chérien way et nous
sommes vraiment nous sommes vraiment
très fiers d'être parmi vous ce soir
pour le tedx blois avec qui on lit
vraiment des liens depuis quelques mois
et avec qui on a les mêmes valeurs
artistiques et familiale qui sont en
fait tourner autour du partage pour eux
pour finir cette conclusion je voudrais
juste vous dire que pour nous plein de
petites choses peuvent emmener à de très
grandes choses si on les fait ensemble
et en tant qu'ambassadeur de dollar on
sait que la musique c'est quelque chose
qui peut changer le monde de manière
positive et tout comme toutes sortes
d'idées 1
aujourd'hui nous allons vous interpréter
une chanson une composition a capella
donc je vous invite à partager avec nous
ce moment à le prendre pour vous parce
que c'est aussi votre moment et nous
allons vivre ce moment ensemble parce
que c'est le titre de ce morceau
ensemble
mais alors qui sonna june et filles à
une nana nicolas mas sovanna
johnny da oui mi-temps djemaï hanna
fathy nasa tamoule ne tient ni à barra
maninona l'uniforme pjanic aux usa
en valais la plupart qui se noie
ni valeo et chez les wade année
[Musique]
kamal où tu vas tu n'as beau
à minuit fou fait nous fit chabadabada
nous yara depuis qu'un bien dormi du
viala
1 go
capital
et sega a nourri narry 'j'ai du
webinaire
un jour après jour la vie se dégradent
ou tout autour la haine remplace l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
me disait souvent fait attention mon
enfant car je le comprenais pas
wouah
pourquoi tant de méfiance
on se demande où est la cause car les
réponses à ces questions où elles sont
ce que je sais c'est que l'union fait la
fois
or au saut le coeur plein de mousse nous
vaincrons la vie et ses détours en 100
ans
1 la madone hama
reconstruisant aubin le lendemain
on sent
le club de mourinho nous vacquerolles
avis et ses détours en sang
au soir
haut la main dans la main
un reconstruisant op le lendemain
en reconstruisant en paix nous lendemain
nourry n'a ni jo ni aux abymes
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]